ever notice how vacation days seem to
last forever while work weeks disappear
in a blur that's not just your
imagination it's
Neuroscience the memory Mirage is the
illusion that productive days are good
days but our brains create memories
based on sensory experiences not
completed tasks the average person
spends nearly half their waking hours
with their mind wandering literally
missing half their life your 17 waking
hours divide into four energy phases
that should determine when you do
activities fighting these natural
rhythms reduces performance by
30% your perfect day isn't about doing
more it's about experiencing more
through sensory awareness even a 5minute
genuine conversation can boost
performance for two hours afterward the
perfect day is designed to be truly
lived and remembered and that perfect
day is available to you starting
tomorrow